bei mir im studio ist jetzt frank
schneider chefreporter hier bei bild und
auch unser experte für polizeieinsätze
wenn du das jetzt hörst zwei überfälle
so kurz hintereinander vor allem jetzt
in berlin wo wir jetzt schon mehrere
solcher überfälle in letzter zeit hatten
was sagst du dazu müssen dass profis
gewesen sein die das mussten keine
profis gewesen sein die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist natürlich schon
da aufgrund der räumlichen nähe das ist
möglicherweise zusammenhänge gibt aber
das lässt sich ja sehr schnell klären
weil alle banken heute überwacht sind
mit videoüberwachung da sieht man ja
sehr schnell ist es wirklich der selbe
täter hatte die gleiche kleidung an
wer wer ist derjenige das kann natürlich
sein dass möglicherweise komplizen mit
dem fluchtwagen dorthin gefahren sind
und was wird jetzt die polizei klären
ungewöhnlich ist nur dass in berlin sich
diese taten jetzt so häufen
normalerweise ist bankraub ich will mal
so zu sagen bei kriminellen etwas aus
der mode geraten
aus einem einfachen grund weil banken
mittlerweile so hohe
sicherheitsstandards haben
und das so gut mit dem geld hinbekommen
haben dass man eben nicht mehr den
großen kassenbestand hat wo sozusagen
der täter sein kann
jetzt gibt mir das geld was in der kasse
liegt das ist normalerweise immer zeit
schloss gesichert das geld muss immer
jedes mal jedem abhebevorgang hochgeholt
werden
deswegen ist es wie gesagt mit
banküberfällen eigentlich weniger
geworden was die täter zuletzt versuchen
da hatten wir den sehr spektakulären
fall hier in berlin mit einer ramme hat
man versucht die bank auf zusammen und
zwar morgens noch vor schalteröffnung wo
aber schon angestellten der bank waren
und das ist so ein neuer trend dass man
versucht angestellte zu bedrohen als
geiseln zu nehmen und dann zu erzwingen
dass man in den safe kommt in den
tresorraum kommt und dort eben geld zu
erbeuten und da prüft die polizei bis
heute auch klare verbindungen gibt es da
möglicherweise verbindung in das clan
milieu wir hatten ja auch hier
spektakuläre überfälle auf geldboten und
auf geldtransporter auch da muss man
eben klären
1 noch dazu gesagt in corona zeiten
hatte sich sozusagen die kriminalität
etwas verlagert wir hatten massive blitz
einbrüche in banken gerade geldautomaten
wurden immer gesprengt das war eine
extrem starke zunahme warum das jetzt
mit den banken plötzlich so ist und wie
die täter sich an stellen ein stück weit
sind sie ja keine profis weil zb bei
einer tat hier in berlin haben sie auch
überhaupt gar keine beute gemacht da
wird etwas dilettantisch einmal wurde
sogar geschossen ein wachmann
angeschossen dass andere hatten sie
verfasst das ist ein bisschen
ungewöhnlich weil es immer wieder
verschiedene ja modus operandi sind weil
die polizei wird natürlich jetzt klären
anhand wie gesagt auch der über
wartungs bilder und zeugenaussagen ob es
da zusammenhänge gibt was ob es eine
zufällige häufung wirklich ist auch am
heutigen morgen in reiner zufall ist
fällt einem natürlich schwer zu glauben